let's talk about Starbucks because
they're actually doing something that's
pretty cool they've announced that
they're going to be paying for tuition
for two years of online classes at
Arizona State University for some of
their employees we've got some more info
about 70% of Starbucks 135 thousand US
employees have not completed
undergraduate degrees employees can now
choose any of more than 40 undergraduate
degrees and aren't limited to only
business classes so you can do whatever
you want which is cool because a lot of
people working at Starbucks are doing it
so that they can become artists or
whatever they whatever they want to be
employees aren't required to stay with
the company after receiving their
degrees and tuition is approximately
thirty thousand for two years I mean
this is real this is a real investment
that they're making with their employees
understanding that these people are not
always going to be with them and they're
going to go fulfill their own dreams
pretty great right
no but it's fantastic because a lot of
times you're getting these shots and
they just want to hold you there they
don't want you to grow they want you to
stay in your position so they can make
money off of you this is like the
complete reverse they're giving you
money and giving you wings so you can
fly into something else yeah thanks
great so isn't that the real beauty of
this whole operation and it's totally
counterintuitive to a business model to
get you to a place where you don't have
to work at that company anymore and I'm
suspicious I don't know what I don't
even know what I'm suspicious of but I
know I'm suspicious because this is it
seems too good to be true they don't
care what you major in they'll pay for
it they don't care if you start if you
work at Starbucks continue online
classes and quit they don't really care
as long as you're working what twenty
hours a week it's too good I'm afraid
there's gonna be a catch well how much
does this kind of stuff make you want to
go to Starbucks so when you hear that
they give all their employees health
insurance you know before Obamacare or
whatever did that effect even if their
coffee isn't the greatest I actually
think is pretty good but I don't even
care if they burn their beans I'm so
excited that they're doing this I think
this is really I mean truly if people
through the American history you join
the military to get a benefit like this
yeah and this is just you know make a
couple double lattes god bless all those
dealing with people in the morning
before they've had their coffee can be
quite like a war
you know sure I just think this is so
phenomenal I just hope that we're all
not being duped because it's so good and
it's it's just so good of them yeah how
much of this comes do you think from
like just the business perspective of
just people talking about it like we're
talking about and they get that good
that goodwill versus like sort of a real
genuine caring for their employees they
may not matter which actually I think we
all consider corporations that a person
we all complain about a $5 latte but if
you're not telling me
oh a dollar of your $5 goes to help
young Megan here achieve her goals of
being the neurosciences can you become a
neuroscientist online at Arizona State
University I don't Megan what she can't
I don't make this about Megan